I sense a disturbance in the force oh
don't act surprised that I have a red
lightsaber so there has been some words
coming out of various people associated
with the Star Wars production that would
seem to indicate that episode 9 to be
directed by JJ Abrams
is going to be the final chapter in the
Skywalker saga I suppose not the final
chapter in Star Wars trust me they're
gonna still make up Star Wars movies but
that this would be the conclusion for
the numbered saga effectively there are
a few things a few people have said that
seemed to indicate that Kathleen Kennedy
has said some things Daisy Ridley has
indicated that she does not intend to
play Rey past episode 9 and I you know
we can debate whether or not this is
gonna actually be the case I want to
right now assume that it is because I
think it's an incredibly good idea
here's why um well I'm just gonna ramble
on about why I say here's why is if I
have a single point that I'm getting to
but one of the major hang-ups or
concerns that I had going into the force
awakens which judging by my comments
section I liked a heck of a lot more
than you guys did but in any case one of
the major concerns I had going in is I
really did worry that coming into a
story set after the end of Return of the
Jedi where the conflict seemed to still
be going on inherently undermined the
victory at the end of Return of the Jedi
it's like I thought we won why is this
still going on now I actually think that
the force awakens managed to sidestep my
concerns on that with one major thing
which is there is a big gap of time
there are years decades that happen
between the end of Return of the Jedi
and the start of the force awakens and
more to the point it's not literally the
Empire now the new Ward is very
obviously has the trappings of the
Empire probably co-opted some of the
resources of the Empire fine but it's
not literally the same thing ah hi you
didn't really win
and I'm ultimately I'm more okay with
that and it's also part of the reason
that I you know didn't really get into a
lot of the between movie stuff there was
like there was the comic book series
there was a four-issue many data read it
was okay but all the stuff that's set in
between I don't I don't want those
answers I don't want to hear about how
oh the Battle of Endor didn't really win
and then all this stuff like I don't I
want that to have been a victory and I
don't want that diminished and again I
don't I think as far as restricting it
to the movies and not any of the other
material I do think that the force
awakens managed to dodge that bullet
fairly decently but regardless of how
well any individual entries theoretical
future entry manages to dodge that on a
one by one basis continuing to go past
Episode nine would inevitably diminish
the importance of just for starters the
original trilogy because the further you
keep going and the further especially if
you keep raising the stakes and you know
oh now here's this thing that's
threatening the galaxy and this thing
and this thing it just it inevitably
makes what Luke Han Leia did feel like
it didn't matter
like what did it accomplish the fighting
didn't stop the fighting never stops
there's always a new huge threat and
there are ways to do narratives about
that there are ways to do great stories
that are look evil will never be
defeated but it's important to fight
anyway but that's not what Star Wars is
that has not been the vibe of Star Wars
as a franchise really ever so I don't
think trying to graph that onto this
franchise is a good idea so staying true
to the space opera fantasy nature of the
thing I think it's much better to have
what feels like a definitive victory
which previously Return of the Jedi gave
us and they're giving us more after that
and again I did enjoy force awakens and
I am looking forward to the last Jedi
but I think closing out the Skywalker
saga specifically is a good idea cuz you
know beyond what I've just said it's
going to just diminish
not only the actions of those characters
from the original trilogy it's going to
diminish the characters themselves
because at this point Han Solo has been
killed off in this in the series we lost
Carrie Fisher so that's going to be an
exit for Princess Leia
Mark Hamill I love him and I hope he
keeps unchecking for a while but he
can't keep doing this forever and I
think inevitably if they keep moving for
we're gonna lose those ties the to the
original thing and it's just not it's
either not gonna feel right or even if
it works it's going to make it so what
they did the old characters like oh well
they don't really matter now and I know
that's my nostalgia talking cuz I grew
up in those characters I grew up in the
original trilogy this is me being
selfish I can admit that but the thing
is I don't think it's overly selfish
because they're already showing they're
more than willing to give us more Star
Wars movies that are not the main saga
now those have had rocky productions up
to this point
I enjoyed rogue one quite a bit but you
can see where it it's pretty disjointed
up until the third act where it's
amazing Han Solo that boy the way that
the making of that has gone I will be
real curious to see that but more in a
is this even gonna be coherent way than
assuming it's gonna be any good it was a
idea that I was if he about in the first
place
josh trank was supposed to do a boba
fett movie that definitely didn't happen
but I think this is why cuz there was
news a couple of weeks ago about Rian
Johnson the writer and director for
Episode eight being put on a separate
film trilogy of Star Wars that is not
going to be the main saga the numbered
saga and at the time those four sounds
I'm like that seems odd now it makes a
heck of a lot more sense because they're
implying that the numbered saga
effectively the Skywalker saga is going
to be brought to a conclusion but
there's there is still and I believe
this to be true still and by far more
than enough stories to be told in these
universe to not only give us new and
Vigil standalone movies like road one
was that sort of fits into what we
already know but to tell whole new
little epics in their own right that
just aren't it's somehow tied into what
happened before but are still setting
that universe is still identifiable as
Star Wars and it's very obvious that
Rian Johnson has had a terrific working
relationship with Lucasfilm with
Kathleen Kennedy they just both sides he
says how great it was to work with them
how they never got in his way and they
haven't gone on and on about how happy
they were with everything he put out so
this makes a lot of sense to basically
hand over to him what the future of
whatever Star Wars will be once episode
9 hits and that wraps up the Skywalker's
I think that is a really good way to
keep the brand going without diminishing
what we've already been given and I
think in a lot of it now that Star Wars
is in theaters again you know it's night
it was initially nice to have the ties
bagged to have the things that we
recognize but Star Wars is back now and
I don't think it's in any way invalid to
start to treat Star Wars a little bit
more like the Marvel Universe and that's
not me saying like Marvel does
everything great everyone should do it
like Marvel that's not the case but I do
think that model does work pretty well
in a certain way when applied to Star
Wars and what I mean by that is each
individual franchise in the Marvel
Universe doesn't have to touch the other
ones some of them are incredibly
self-contained I mean it's going to
cross over with a menu Avengers infinity
Wars but guardians of the galaxy for two
movies has been completely its own thing
like not even connected to the other
stuff at all
Ant Man had very superficial ties to
anything else and yeah that sort of
stuff is is all over the place and I
think Star Wars can start to adopt that
same approach where okay we have we
originally it grew out of this but now
we can have this story in this will be
three movies and of this story this will
just be one movie but then that can be
this and this and I think that is the
good way to move forward without losing
or diminishing or devaluing the core of
what the franchise has been up to this
point because I think if you try and you
try and stray
which that main story any further than
nine episodes and we'll even see if it
works for the nine but I really think or
garlis stretching it beyond that is just
gonna be it's gonna be diminishing
returns not just at the box office but
for fans and for the value of Star Wars
as a property as a universe so I think
this is a really good idea assuming that
what's being implied is in fact the case
and we I didn't just miss read
everything but what are your thoughts on
the idea that episode 9 is effectively
the end of the Skywalker story but we
still get other Star Wars stories that
are not connected to that what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks or listening to the
council of geeks podcast that is
available on Apple podcasts as well as
stitcher radio I'm also 1/2 of the punch
like a girl podcast that's a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network fire and water
podcast.com and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]